hey guys what's up welcome to our
podcast this week this is me Jenna
Jillian podcast Jenna just got
caffeinated yeah sorry I almost could
human I was drinking
five after October juice good
caffeinated on camera thank you it on
mic yeah you do you want
so today's podcast might not be on the
funnier side there's currently something
happening as we're podcasting yeah we've
been watching the Baltimore riots
basically on a live stream all day yeah
right
all day we've been following it
basically all day from this morning till
right now which is about 6:40 and the
evening so I guess philsie who aren't in
on what's going on or those who are not
in the country or any reason why you
don't know what's happening there has
been riots in the city of Baltimore
Maryland basically you know cause I you
know I don't know wasn't caused by but
it's it's it happened after there was a
feeling that a week ago happened with
police
yeah there was a man in police custody
he was twenty five his name was Freddie
gray and he he died in police custody
and there's there's a there's a there's
some kind of details that weren't really
given out in Terraria people no pun
intended
yeah and a lot of people were outraged
and today's they thought that the police
had something to do with him dying
because he died yeah and his funeral was
today and there's been protests
happening all week there's been protests
happening all weekend I think it's
important that we do we distinguish the
word protest from what else happened
today because today we there was a lot
of violence in Baltimore there were
riots there was looting
yeah well mean what happened there were
a bunch of high school students that put
on social media that they wanted to
march from I forget where to I forget
where yeah you're going to March and the
police had saw that and
they were there preemptively and these
high school kids basically turned into a
[ __ ] riot yeah and they started
throwing stones there were what last I
heard somewhere between seven and
fifteen cops injured yeah one was
unresponsive people injured yeah it was
serious I mean watching the stream was
was pretty terrifying because because we
were watching this live stream of what
was happening on the lake all day it was
terrifying because there's nothing in
every store I mean it could like not
even getting to the point of where
people are like smashing windows and
stealing stuff and setting fire the the
violence against the cops is what is the
most terrifying to me because yeah you
know obviously it's in this really
really shitty position where the cops
can't retaliate if these people or else
they find themselves in a situation just
like what caused this one right you
don't want to cause any more deaths yeah
in the situation and you know there's
lines and lines of cops obviously not
enough cops because there's backing up
and they're literally set up these
things these riots as they want to kill
the cops
yes and some people were saying that
they were organized by gangs or you know
younger kids that basically have nothing
to [ __ ] lose yeah give a [ __ ] yeah
but it clearly like when you're watching
the riots they have nothing to do with
the person that died they have
everything to do with people being
vigilantes so much it wasn't organized
it was nothing that was just people
smashing cop cars and lighting cars on
fire and we're currently watching for
fires yeah someone had lit the frame of
what was supposed to be a senior
citizens home they lit the wooden frame
on fire so they were building it was
under construction and the embers of
that fire have now spread to people's
homes like houses people's houses are
now on fire right and when this was
happening earlier today and I turned on
the livestream I was I was sort of
looking through like I have a list on
Twitter of like youtubers comedians a
list onion on like any sort of celebrity
and like yep some people care but the
amount of people that didn't care or
didn't even like acknowledge it that
we're just sort of whatever where it
sort of baffles me sometimes when
something like so you cannot ignore it
that's going on in our country and that
people are like have no problem just
posting selfies and being
don't know where I saw I saw that today
and I did get really bugged by it
because you know the fact that you were
in a position where you have the ability
to affect change in a situation like
this not I mean you know even if you're
just a normal person who doesn't have
any sort of following the fact that you
need to be clued in on this stuff is so
important it's like your country these
are things that are happening right now
they're important you can't just turn
your head at them you can't you know not
acknowledge the fact that they are
serious serious and horrible things
happening so what you use and you know
the selfie thing I saw that today and it
bugged me a little bit and even even if
you're not doing anything you don't have
to have an opinion it like what all I
said was like I'm just watching the live
stream Wow I tweeted out a link to a
live stream because I think it's
important for people to know what
actually there was a number of people
who did what you did I saw Nev from
catfish was posting about it saying guys
pay attention this is happening it's
important and you know you know it's not
like it's not so much so that you need
to tell everyone like oh this is my
opinion on things like you said you
don't need to put your opinion out there
but to do the direct opposite and put it
out there that you are actively not
aware of what's going on by posting just
an unassuming selfie during something
like this or that you don't care it's
pretty it's it's it's it's just a you
know it's not a big problem it's just
something that agitates us I think and
you said just before that it does these
angered you know kind of violent people
who have been rioting violently
throughout the the city of Baltimore
today they they aren't there they don't
have a direct correlation from the gray
death and in fact so much so that the
family of Freddie gray has died at the
funeral we want this to be a day of
peace we don't want any fan testing they
said they don't want protests that was a
peaceful but I mean they asked for that
and the fact that these people who have
been so completely just disobedient and
crazy today just show I mean how out of
touch with with the whole situation they
are and I think they're not only not you
know serving any sort of purpose at this
point but they're they're they're
exposing too
everyone the entire world is watching
Baltimore they're exposing how badly
people can behave in the event of chaos
in the event of like a you know a
tragedy yeah and it showed a major
weakness you know people are criticizing
mayor that she took like five hours to
actually sort of respond to what was
going on and they she's quoted earlier
this morning is saying that she they
wanted to give the people that were
being violent space and people had a
problem with that word space or like
you're literally just letting them cause
chaos do something about it she's got a
lot of flack for that but you're kind of
in a position where you can't win
because the system is you know kind of
corrupt at this point there's some dirty
[ __ ] cops a lot of bad [ __ ] has been
happening like Ferguson and all these
things going on is really bringing it to
everyone's attention that this is a big
issue this this stuff really [ __ ]
matters it's getting worse it's not
getting better and like no these people
that were rioting today are not what
normal people would do this is a small
group well you know it catches on like
it started off as high school students
that were rioting and then they cut to a
couple hours later it's just full grown
adults out there that's really
disappointing the seasons right but we
it's important that everyone is paying
attention to what's happening and it
just sort of bothers me when people
don't care yeah you know what I mean
they don't [ __ ] give a [ __ ] yeah
that's it's it's definitely it's a
frustrating thing and you mentioned that
you know she got kind of hate from for
saying that we need to give them space
we need the police to kind of back off
and not get right in there and we were
watching the stream today and what what
you just said reminded me of the point
where there was a scam Miguel what was
his name Miguel there was a reporter of
a CNN he was in there like in there in
the middle of everything he had his
fault he was listening to his you know
the studio on his phone because his
receiver and his IFB wouldn't work so
his mind can eat his phone and he was in
the middle of everything and he was
really just trying to explain everything
from the ground of it happening and
there was this guy who he you know he
let talk into the mic and this guy was
like you know you know this is my
problem like you know
the reason that this is happening is the
way that the cops are handling it like
earlier today the cops weren't doing
anything and that's a problem and I
disagree with that I think the fact that
they are refraining from getting in and
directly conflicting as much as they can
help it is only to like self preserve
they cannot afford to go in and then
have hand-to-hand combat and have people
die right and like you said earlier
today like the way that they were
rioting you cannot bring police into a
situation where they openly know that
their lives are being threatened and
expect no violence I mean it's a war
zone
you look at the stream it's [ __ ] what
what is our choice do we go in there and
stop it knowing that violence is
currently occurring and will occur to a
greater level or do we pull back what do
we do you can't win you can't win it's a
lose-lose situation and unfortunately I
think what they did today as nasty and
as gross it was to watch is the right
move they had to kind of just stay as
compact in the unit the cops with their
riot gear as possible while moving in
but also not moving too far in and you
kind of just have to let this [ __ ]
happen like all this damage going on
it's like what what are they to do like
you know there's no giant like there's
no what I was talking to Jen about
earlier there's there's no mass form of
arresting people you can't like throw a
giant net over a groupie okay you're all
arrested there's no way to do that like
non-violently right and what what I was
starting to go earlier I was talking
earlier is that this kind of points out
like that there is a weakness in cities
to be able to deal with a riot on this
scale joining me absolutely Baltimore is
a fairly large it's like your fifth
largest in the u.s. in the United States
and you know they these high school kids
kind of pointed out just what can happen
when a bunch of people decide to
organize themselves and create something
violent yeah it's kind of [ __ ]
terrifying it's scary
and it's unfortunate that takes
something like this to really open our
eyes and say well reinforcements from
all over the place everyone's like well
why isn't anyone coming it kind of takes
a long [ __ ] time to organize that
many police officers yeah the scale of
what's going on is kind of right kind of
unpress
and it's not like something that we were
previously prepared for like obviously
they're prepared for protests and
they're not prepared for a riot on this
scale and I was so frustrated that's why
I was watching the livestream earlier
today I was so frustrated that in Los
Angeles we could not get one single
[ __ ] news station that was providing
us with any live stream it took way too
long
we were watching there was KTLA 5 we
were watching ABC 7 and they both were
going back and forth there was like a
segment on the Apple watch for like 20
minutes during this like and they
finally adjusted and went to the live
shot of basically CNN and this local
news station of Baltimore but it took
him forever cut to the weatherman with
his giant [ __ ] teeth like 27 times
talking about how there's sunshine yeah
like it really bothers me and I think
that I think that's part of the problem
it perpetuates the culture of not really
caring unless it's in our [ __ ] back
door I mean I mean this is they declared
a state of emergency it's technically by
definition and emergency and the fact
that not every single news station
across the entire the United States is
not showing live streams of this
non-stop commentating on what's
happening getting the word out I mean
it's just in my opinion it's a little
bit irresponsible like we're saying it's
a bigger scale of being a person on the
on on Twitter on the internet with reach
who's not giving any sort of attention
to it posting a selfie hey guys happy
Monday you know this is this that's
that's a smaller scale of it
responsibility and I think this news
station kind of neglecting to just give
everything to this the forefront of the
news today is is bigger right I mean it
what happened today is horrible and not
okay and I'm honestly although we
haven't gotten an official like number
of how many people were injured or
possibly killed like this could have
gone much worse than it did no this is
[ __ ] terrible but you could have if
the police had moved in there could have
been more deaths a lot of deaths and
like it's sort of sad to me that because
people aren't paying attention they they
don't they don't understand what's how
while it's happening yeah you know what
I mean like the people on the news kept
being like parents tell your kids to
come home because they're assuming that
their parents are standing there
watching the [ __ ] news yeah you know
II mean clearly like these people's
parents either don't know or you know
they're they're at a job like you're
talking about probably like middle-class
working people they're at work that
don't they don't have the ability to
know where their kid is from 3 o'clock
to 5:30 yeah Jeremy yeah that's what's
so sad about it these kids you know
you're free when you swing school's over
they can go on the [ __ ] stance
absolutely
you know what I mean absolutely but
whatever it bothers me that people don't
care while it's happening although it
was the number one trending topic on
Twitter pretty much all day there was
still so much like social
irresponsibility of people with any sort
of reach that were you know trying to
help people understand hey kid guess
what if there's a [ __ ] riot in your
town some day and you want it to be a
big deal and you want people to know
about it
good [ __ ] luck because apparently no
one gives a [ __ ] yeah I mean it's just
the whole situation from A to Z it's
disappointing
the reason it's happening the way it's
being handled the way people are
effecting change on it or lack thereof I
mean it's just every angle of this is
ugly and we'll see what happens because
there's a protest scheduled first
Saturday yeah I mean which is five days
away now that it's you know officially a
state of emergency they've moved in the
National Guard and stuff I think that
they're much more prepared than they
were now yeah for something like this
happened they're aware of what's
happened just to deal with it yeah but I
mean it's [ __ ] and yeah and there was
either the governor and the mayor both
got on today of Maryland and Spokane you
see it in their in their face they're
just the utter like disappointment of
like the fact that the people of this
city the line destroying their own City
own City they're choosing to act like
you know this you know just inhumane
people like just you know that's that's
kind of a contradiction but they're just
they're just they're digressing into
such
violence for no reason and it's so the
opposite of constructive that like if I
were a resident of Maryland I would feel
so upset I'm like helpless like what
it's so what propels people to suddenly
just turning a switch this tragedy
happened now I turn into a person who's
just gonna wreck shop I'm gonna
mindlessly destroy things I'm gonna hurt
people
it really wasn't connected whatsoever
but the people of Baltimore are angry no
absolutely you are angry against the
police and they have the right to be
angry there's a lot of wrong and
happening but the the police people they
keep becoming more and more militarized
joining me they have [ __ ] riot gear
the police now do not look like the
police even when I was growing up you
don't have tanks driving through [ __ ]
crowds of people it's it's more and more
the separation of power is so [ __ ]
big but this is really kind of crazy
that this is the first time that the
police weren't immediately able to sort
of like shut down and stop rioting yeah
these kids they kind of just had to ride
it out really just they they sort of
decided that they were gonna [ __ ]
riot and they rioted and it was horror
it was it was scary to watch that
mentality but that usually what you see
is [ __ ] tanks and riot gear the SWAT
teams around civilians you know I mean
and it's that is also equally on another
like skill equally as terrifying to see
like what if you know some conspiracy
theory whatever the police decided that
they were gonna enslave all of us into a
[ __ ] you know government where we had
no rights yeah we can't we can't fight
against tanks and swats and [ __ ] all
of that [ __ ] yeah we're civilians so
it's sort of terrifying that teenagers
were able to like destroy any sort of
plan than that Baltimore could have had
for this riot and it's also terrifying
when you see the other spectrum of that
where it's like tear gas like all this
[ __ ] stuff we we can't we have no
defense exactly there's like people are
angry because their people keep getting
killed our [ __ ] young people keep
getting [ __ ] killed by the police
it's just bad all around yeah it's a win
case
a weird cycle man and it's like we've
done this to ourselves like the way that
people have behaved in the way cops have
behaved and the way they you know
civilians have reacted it's kind of just
created this weird dynamic to where
whenever this happens we face this like
okay now there's gonna be a riot and now
how violent is the police have to get to
stop it but not hurt anyone
and then today was like a great example
of like oh they can't do anything you
know either they go in there with rubber
bullets and start [ __ ] hurting
people or they back off and they
literally just try to contain it as best
they can which leads to fires leads to
looting leads to citywide disruption I
mean it's like so obscene I couldn't get
over that so they were looting the CVS
yeah
which has been a lift which has a
pharmacy in it mind you so there's just
[ __ ] drugs being stolen all over the
place fine whatever then they decided to
just light the CVS on fire yeah like
what the actual [ __ ] they were putting
out the CVS buyer and somebody stabbed
the hose that they were putting out the
fire with yeah it's senseless
it's like we were watching maybe 10
minutes ago and some [ __ ] guy flipped
off the camera like this woman was
standing outside of the the four fires
that were burning that was transferring
into residential homes and this guy pay
on the camera over and he just flips the
[ __ ] champ I was a the guy we killed
that reporter I believe his name yeah I
was looking at his Twitter and his
pictures from a couple days ago and he
had like tweeted a picture it was jacket
and he's like some woman spit on me
telling me that CNN is Miss resent
misrepresenting African Americans and he
was like it's getting weird and I'm not
gonna speak for CNN because I don't
really know what you know what they were
saying or why they might have been yeah
but it's just the bottom line is it's
just like knots out there people are
angry and they don't know how to deal
with it they don't know how to they
don't know how to constructively
participate that everyone's so
frustrated and pissed off and it's just
got reached this weird kind of barbaric
precipice where today people are just
throwing rocks at human beings right so
yeah we get it what you're very angry
and we're all angry
we don't want any more people dying at
the hands of the police wrongfully but
you know it's not gonna help you just
lighting a bunch of [ __ ] fires we
Phil DeFranco GC is tweet he tweet a
picture of the CBS on Friday said I too
like to light on my local CBS on fire
when I don't agree with something I love
Phil it's just it's so disheartening
it's frustrating on so many levels
I mean because like you and me talk
about this situation and I'm sure lots
and lots of other people can have this
conversation and say you know in this
situation you know one of my fellow you
know citizens of my city got wrongfully
murdered maybe and I'm angry about it
what am I gonna do and like you may not
be able to answer that question with a
specific answer but you know you're not
gonna do that like you know that there's
you know in your mind there are so many
different things that you're gonna go
through even in the state of anger that
is not that so it's like wild to me how
so many people are just well I mean the
way that it started honestly I can
understand why it escalated to that you
get a group of teenagers that all have
peer pressure
yeah I'm forgetting that it's like young
people that's who started it is fun when
you're in a group of teenagers and you
see somebody throw a brick through a cop
car yeah you know what I mean that gets
everybody fired up and then that's how
things escalate yeah and then once
everybody sees things that are burning
okay cool might as well go rob a
7-eleven cuz no one's gonna know that I
did it and then looting of one store
turns into looting of ten stores turns
into fires turns into anybody that wants
to get away with anything they can yep I
think you're right you know what I mean
but the fact that matter is that young
people with you know a different
conscience than someone that's a
full-grown adult that was thinking
clearly yeah just don't [ __ ] care
yeah they haven't really developed a
sense of you know the repercussions of
the way some things will go down right
because it's it's not only repercussions
of like you know what what what will my
friends do or what will people around me
do whether people know what will we do
as a group together because when you're
in a group of young teenagers what you
do together is worse than what you would
do buyers absolutely it's the mob
mentality right you find yourself doing
things that you would normally do
because you're behind this veil of other
people actually but what they don't
realize is that once the rest of the
world sees that someone has cast the
first stone
alright now [ __ ] it let's [ __ ] watch
this [ __ ] building burn you wanna
mean they don't realize how much that
just like them by themselves will
influence everyone else absolutely I
just I mean it bothered me that you know
we were getting a lack of news coverage
it bothered me that there is a lack of
coverage on urgency from anybody on
Twitter
and I mean it's just disappointing all
around and we were also talking earlier
not to switch topics completely what we
were talking about earlier about how
there was a [ __ ] that crazy
earthquake in Nepal killed four thousand
people four thousand people had an
aftershock of like a six point whatever
magnitude are you after the fact people
are sleeping outside and we live in
California but we could have one of
those day and I think what's crazy about
that is first of all with all these
things combined there was a train that
blew up tracks in Louisiana we saw that
it was like crazy like a truck that was
on fire yeah a bunch of stories it was
like it feels very apocalyptic and the
first thing that I said I was like is it
a full [ __ ] moon today yeah so it's
coming a couple days right right yes in
six days there will be a full moon so
get everyone's crazy but I mean it's wow
that you say you know you remind us that
you live in California just as bad
damage and just as tragic earthquakes
can happen in where we live and if it
happened in California the entire
country would go upside down people
would be like holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
California second California Los Angeles
Hollywood got hit with this thing we
need to fix it but because it's Nepal
it's like oh you know it's kind of oh
yeah they're hurt but the lack of a
sense of urgency although I have seen
some people a lot of people there's a
lot out links directly there's a lot of
people who have followings who are being
very awesome about it and I think that's
great and I think the power of the
Internet makes these types of
it's way easier to contribute to the you
know resolving of but what's still kind
of sad justice I agree but what I think
is crazy about the earthquake situation
is that you know in Los Angeles we have
deemed earthquakes as something that
we're willing to live with do you know
what I mean yeah the weather's beautiful
you know it's nice whatever
earthquakes yeah well they only happen
every once in a while yeah and but like
the East Coast they deal with snow for
[ __ ] six months out of the year
they've deemed that is something that
they're willing to live with ice storms
all of that kind of thing hurricanes you
know the tornado alley and stuff they've
deemed tornadoes is something they're
willing to live with people that live
near volcanoes okay I will live with
that you have to decide like sort of
what your what natural disaster we like
to live with yeah but most of Los
Angeles and my opinion have deemed
earthquakes as something that they're
willing to live with but do not know
what to do in the case of an earthquake
and I think a perfect example of that is
when we lived on the other side of the
hill and there was an earthquake and you
know we it woke us up in the middle of
the night it was like under our house
basically yeah the epicenter we turn on
the news after was over felt it wasn't
even that bad it was like a three point
whatever right and you know it woke us
up on like 6:00 in the morning we turn
on the news it felt like it was shaking
for-fucking-ever and it really wasn't
the dogs are going crazy you turn on the
news and you know they're doing their
schmooze e whatever news coverage and
they get somebody on the phone and
they're like alright you know give us
some tips on on how to deal with an
earthquake and they're like okay you
gotta get to your bathtub and then lay
down like no no no and they cut off the
collar and they were like that's not
correct don't listen to that okay let's
get another person on the phone
okay you gotta get to a door you gotta
stand in the door there is a serious
serious lack of information going around
Los Angeles that would prepare people
for that type of disaster to happen here
because most people don't have a [ __ ]
clue there's little ones that happen all
the time and people are like
Oh better get on Twitter yeah they have
no idea yeah what to do in that scenario
my dad I mean we and earthquake the
other day yeah but my dad texted me and
I like chuckled at the text but it you
know it was it was an important thing he
said he said you know you know be safe
have a plan in place that's all he said
and I you know I was like that's you
know I I appreciate that because you
know as much as it was a mild earthquake
and maybe we've only had mild ones for
the last for how long whatever all it
takes is one and there you really need
to know what the [ __ ] to do I even told
you and I was like hey like my dad just
texted me we still have like that jug of
water and that in the sabian water we
got like canned beans and you know stuff
to eat and stuff to have but like it's
you're absolutely right there's no
there's no you know broad set of
information or set of kind of no
protocol really for people who really
know that is kind of follow well where I
grew up the way that we were educated
was we were educated heavily for house
fires for like lightning strikes and
what to do when there's a big storm what
do you do if you're in the middle of a
field like where do you go what do you
do basically because that was you know
the most that we had to deal with was if
your house catches on fire or if you're
caught in a big giant storm what should
you do or like a lot of snow there's a
good storm right yeah you know what do
you do but we didn't have to prepare for
earthquake yeah yeah it's shocking to me
that people can live in a place where
you know it's possible to have that like
magnitude of a disaster happen and
people don't have a clue as to what to
do yeah well I mean just to be devil's
advocate a little bit earthquakes are a
little bit dicey in terms of what you do
when they happen okay you know it's it's
a little different than other natural
disasters in that like a whole building
could just tumble over like in a split
second and you're like okay what the
[ __ ] but you're absolutely right I still
I still do agree you know yeah the fact
that there's so much conflicting
information like how some people say
getting a door where someone's getting
your bathtub you know I mean so it's
like you really have to you you really
do
totally agree that an earthquake is a
different type of natural disaster than
many other ones because it can hit at
any time without any buzzing and you can
be in any place so you can't really you
know be prepared like tornadoes also hit
and people have like legitimate shelters
to live in because they know how serious
they are
and it sorta baffles me a little bit
that there's no scale of education like
people when there's a tornado coming
although they will have time they can
get to public places where they have
like these shelters built there are
people in that scenario yep but like
there's okay I'll give California this
like on Venice Beach and stuff like that
there are tsunami escape science it
literally just has a sign pointing away
from you that way but still I mean
that's something can see right through
you know what I mean if you were
visiting it's almost like you have no
idea like that's one of the biggest
tourist spots in the United States like
Santa Monica here and all that area that
Beach and people have not a [ __ ] clue
what to do yeah like if a tsunami hit
and that first wave that comes in and
everybody starts [ __ ] dancing in it
and stuff like no runaway that's the
warning wave like a lot of people aren't
equipped with that knowledge you know
what I mean yep it sort of makes me a
little bit nervous it yeah it needs to
be fixed
I agree like [ __ ] I was talking about
it with Rome and she was telling I
didn't know this that there's a such a
thing that they call the triangle of
life where if you like get and like you
know how your bed is maybe here if you
get just beside your bed like if
something were to fall from above you it
would hit the bed and then tip so that
you could have a little triangle of life
essentially it's like if the roof hits
you're [ __ ] right if the roof fell
down you're sorry
it would then you know yeah not hit you
and that it could be the difference
between life and death so if you're in
things like that need to be common
knowledge thing if you live here they
need to be I know that and it should be
common knowledge that you should have
rations of water especially when we live
in a place where there is no [ __ ]
water sure you know sure
well I mean
what I mean it's inevitable they happen
absolutely crimes like that happened 150
years or about and we're kind of overdue
for one so that's not on wood but yeah
yeah it's gonna happen yeah but saying
we're overdue for one we are I know but
you're the most superstitious person I
know I'm surprised you're even saying
that jinx anything it's just science
they're plates but anyways I mean I've I
don't know it just feels very
overwhelming today yeah today I feel I
guess you're right it's just a lot it's
a lot to take in and as much as
sometimes I feel like I can only read so
much news in a day and then I'm like
okay you know I got it I gotta go live
my life I gotta you know get this out of
it though because when you like marinate
in it it's very hard to do normal things
because it's very depressing no yeah
because it's so real great today was
just a lot yeah you know so sorry that
the podcast wasn't super light and happy
yeah but you should let us know your
thoughts please do let us know you had
just anything that you feel or think
without getting you know too political
but yes please be respectful of people
in the comments section I think we can
make this a good discussion because a
good discussion is important it you know
it it makes people aware people should
be talking about this more which is why
we chose to to podcast about it honestly
we were we were debating it but then we
thought you know it's it's important we
have a voice here so let's let's podcast
it's important not to [ __ ] just
ignore everything that's yeah yeah well
I mean thank you guys for listening to
the podcast moment to the podcast today
even though like I said it wasn't it
happy if anyone thanks for talking about
this
being on it I think that's important I
will be back next week with another
broadcast wait we're wait we're going to
Canada for a few days and pull them so
you're going to Toronto Fan Fest I will
see you there
I know mixed in who's so [ __ ] bizarre
today mix it with you know people being
like hey if you have a link for the
little live streams like I won tickets
to your meet-and-greet I'm like I don't
even know how to I'm very happy for you
those of you who have one ticket slip
you meet and greet nice job sort of like
we were trying to just focus on this but
um like I said we'll see you guys next
week thanks for watching
[Music]